bonjour à toutes et à tous ac la saison
des piknic et on redécouvre le plaisir
de partager son petit repas de plein air
avec des invités bourdonnante
mais que se passe-t-il dans la tête de
ces petites abeilles paisible ouvrière
pourrait se transforme aussi vite en des
kamikazes déterminés prêts à mourir pour
défendre leurs ruches plusieurs études
ont montré que la défense de la ruche et
collective lorsque les abeilles détecte
une menace elles produisent un ensemble
de molécules qu'on appelle phéromones
d'alarmé pour prévenir les autres
membres de la colonie leurs congénères
ainsi alerter sorte de la ruche à la
recherche de l'ennemi potentiel et se
joignent talent attaque un peu comme nos
armées sauf que l' alerte n'est pas
envoyée par radio mais par phéromones
des chercheurs du centre de cognition
animale de toulouse ont voulu comprendre
ce qu'il se passe dans le cerveau des
abeilles pour déclencher une telle
agressivité à l'arrivée de l'affairé aux
mules pour cela ils sont allés chercher
des abeilles dans des ruches en
utilisant une plume pour les faire
sortir cette méthode garantit que les
abbés récupérer son bien des gardiennes
des fonds dans la ruche et surtout
qu'elle ne meure pas en piquant le leur
petit petit petit petit petit petit
petit avec ses petites abeilles
ils ont réalisé une expérience pour
tester leur comportement face à une
menace en présence et en l'absence de
phéromones d'alarmé
[Musique]
par paire les abeilles gardienne sont
envoyés dans une petite arène circulaire
dans laquelle en leur noir tourner et
les gènes les chercheurs observent alors
la fréquence à laquelle les abeilles pic
oui un petit boudin avec une plume ça
paraît pas une grande menace
mais du point de vue des abbés il faut
vous imaginer face à un immense taureau
mécanique à plumes qui tourne sur lui
même pour vous mettre des grosses boîtes
femmes
ça vous donne pas envie de piquer vous
en l'absence de phéromones d'alarmé
certaines abeilles pic et d'autres se
contentent d'éviter l'obstacle la même
expérience est réalisée en présence de
phéromones hélas sans surprise les
abeilles attaquent plus rapidement et
pique à une fréquence plus élevée à
partir des résultats de ces expériences
ils ont classé les abeilles les abeilles
paisible qui ne pique pas le leur et les
abeilles agressive qu'il attaque les
abeilles au grain d'un côté les abeilles
vénère de l'autre mais les chercheurs
sont allés plus loin dans chaque cas ils
ont analysé le cerveau des abeilles et
mesurer la quantité de trois molécules
star chez spécialiste du comportement
dopamine et la sérotonine et look
stocamine
ces molécules agissent sur les neurones
et la transmission des informations dans
le cerveau ce sont des
neurotransmetteurs des neuromodulateurs
et des neuro hormones mais elles sont
surtout connus pour réguler
l'agressivité chez de nombreuses espèces
d'insectes et de mammifères
chez nous aussi les chercheurs ont
observé que le cerveau des abeilles
agressive était bourré de sérotonine et
ils ont aussi constaté que l'exposition
à phéromones d'alarm augmenter les taux
de dopamine et de sérotonine dans le
cerveau de toutes les abeilles pour
montrer que ces molécules sont bien
responsables de l'agressivité des
abeilles les chercheurs ont recommencé
leurs expériences mais cette fois ci les
cobayes sont préalablement tartiner soit
avec de la dopamine soit avec de la
sérotonine soit avec des produits qui
empêche ces molécules d'agir et la bim
le constat est sans appel les abeilles
les plus chouchoutés à la sérotonine ou
à la dopamine sont celles qui pique le
plus et à linverse celles qui ne
ressentent plus les effets de ces
molécules ne pique plus ces expériences
démontrent donc que c'est en augmentant
la quantité de sérotonine et de dopamine
dans
cerveau que la phéromone d'alarm
provoque le changement de comportement
de l'abbaye et cette quantité peut
varier d'un individu à l'autre en
présence ou pas d'une phéromones alarme
mais aussi en fonction de l'âge la bei
du patrimoine génétique de la ruche et
qui sait peut-être même de la météo
ainsi la diffusion de la phéromone
d'alarm n'en voit pas directement un
signal d' attaque mais augmente la
probabilité que d'autres abeilles aux se
transformer en kamikaze et se rangeant
la bei est un animal que l'humain a
domestiqué depuis la préhistoire et
pourtant on est loin de comprendre
toutes les facettes de son comportement
en étudiant les systèmes de défense de
la bei ces recherches pourraient offrir
de nouvelles possibilités de gestion de
son agressivité pour améliorer les
conditions de travail des apiculteurs
par exemple ou pour compenser l'impact
des pesticides sur leurs comportements
voilà j'espère que cette recherche va
faire le buzz et qu'elle a piqué votre
curiosité
en tout cas moi ça me fout toujours un
peu le bourdon de vous quitter alors je
vous dis au prochain épisode
pas dit mme espiègle maya mais sinon ça
veut dire quoi au klm mais détendue du
dard quoi abonnez vous